لا يمكن تخيل كاس العالم او اي مباراه كره
قدم حول العالم من دون بطاقات حمر وصفر
فهذه البطاقات التي يوجهها الحكام للاعبين
المخالفين بهدف فرضه النظام على اللعبه
باتت تستخدم كاستعارات في الاحاديث بين
الناس عند الكلام عن الطرد والانذار صاحب
فكره البطاقه الصفراء والحمراء هو كن
استون رجل انجليزي توفي في عام 2001 بعد
سلسله من المساهمات في عالم كره القدم
اصلا استوحى فكره البطاقات من اشارات
المرور في الشارع
وترجمها على هيئه ان الاصفر للتهدئه
والاحمر للتوقف وذلك للتغلب على اي حواجز
لغويه وظهرت البطاقات الصفراء والحمراء في
كاس العالم عام 1970 في المكسيك ومنذ ذلك
الحين اصبحت جزءا لا يتجزا من اللعبه الا
انه قبل ذلك كان يحصل الطرد والانذار
بطريقه سهله
[موسيقى]